hey welcome to every damn day watch this
so what we have here is a man dressed
pretty sharp he's in a suit and he's
performing an exorcism as you do on the
subway with a woman and she is hitting
him with an umbrella and they are also
saying back and forth I forgive you to
each other the woman is now saying
spirit spirit spirit spirit he's still
forgiving her just connected with the
umbrella in the name of Jesus I forgive
you and making some connections Natasha
you're enjoying this why do you think
this is a perfect piece of cinema I
don't know it's sometimes it's just
everything aligns you know what I mean
like yeah my reaction when I first
thought was like I was in tears I'm so
glad you brought up when you first saw
it because we actually have a video so
this is from our morning meeting Natasha
enjoyed this video so much we took a
video this is her watching it for real
she's got her headphones in Ainslie
quiet no I think you are crying as
George right now she's waving off the
video we're telling the video to stop
[Laughter]
you said I love it so much wiping away
the tears Georgia thank you as a Jordan
I think as you pointed out that's the
hardest we've seen Natasha laughs so
what's so perfect what do you love it's
like so the fact that he's it is so you
give it away with an umbrella and it's
just like them also they're both saying
I forgive it was this guy was this this
guy's first exorcism has anyone seen
anything close to this on the New York
City Subway I mean I can't believe that
it's real like I just it's crazy to
think like like your mind goes from this
woman
I think she's possessed you know what
the guy in a suit who's going to work or
whatever he's doing it's like you know
what I better do this right now like
smartly dress like two crazy people
[Laughter]
it's such a weird thing to like exercise
another person like they don't know each
other I feel like it's like one step
above like telling a woman to smile like
agreed though she said you're possessed
and she literally said yes it was
perfect approach she said yes and the
blood of such a bad headache or been so
sick I was like I can get it out of you
I've never laughed so hard at someone
laughing so like in person I think that
would have been funnier for me than
actually watching it just watching the
language it was like they were speaking
the same language but they were not each
other it might be like a wily coyote
Roadrunner thing where they do this
every day
and tell me you got me today let us know
what you think of this video and
speaking of comments hey Ryan what's our
what's our top comment from yesterday's
video
yesterday's hot dog poll I got the top
comment right here it comes from Kai
Ward who said quote if anything a hot
dog is a taco so thank you very
progressive stance perhaps I've been
whitewashing my sandwich hierarchy to
taco folks they're older and they kind
of look the same thank you guys all
right we're gonna do something different
right now oh yeah mm-hmm
yeah that's two-way pager makes it
easier for me to play snake thank you
oh man all right cameras are here taught
me to film another back in my day back
in my day fake news with the north but a
fake Waldo couldn't ruin your day
Where's Waldo was a picture book we had
to find a dude named Waldo Waldo was
dressed like a Williamsburg history or
mumble record he wore a red and white
striped shirt glasses a beanie blue
jeans and he had a cane like he was
cooler he had a bad knee I don't know
what's wrong he had a dog named wolf and
a wizard named white beard and a
girlfriend named window who's pretty
much identical I don't even know why
back in my day Waldo was classified as
cool maybe because he hung out with a
wizard figured if he didn't have a job
and you got a wizard you bailed man pull
up some food or something
also he had a girlfriend with no house I
assume he had no house because he was
always outside he went like a festival
or Antarctica or some other exotic place
but I bet you he had dr. dad dog you
know something it's official Waldo was
the first hipster I'm saying it now
back in my day during heat waves in the
hood we would go to the library for the
free air condition I would solve as many
Waldo's as possible and hopefully some
idiot didn't circle Waldo cuz back in my
day it was an unspoken rule you never
supported a movie you didn't talk during
TGIF and you never circle Waldo
will you go seems a better back in my
day now I'm gonna go chill and finish
watching Fresh Prince of bel-air
you know the one with the first outfit
[Music]
hello and welcome to my show and tell
where I show one of my really cool
projects and talk about them with my
work friends today I made a short film
roll the tape please
[Music]
yeah so that's um pretty much the first
draft of the album the first like sort
of close to complete draft what are your
thoughts I'm kind of dying to know
alright um so I was kind of going for
like a synthetic but also like
emotionally authentic kind of thing I
wonder if that came across at all I know
it's pretty weird to crit your friends
especially right in front of him so yeah
won't you just email me what you think
no pressure just be totally honest yeah
no I'll leave you to it okay so we're
gonna do a quick Q&A about that film and
before we start I'm gonna just read a
review of the film that I found on the
surface Jordan Mendoza's listening party
tells the simple tale of a promising
young man seeking approval from his
roommates pet but obviously it's way
more than that in this sweeping 62nd
Kunstler Roman Jordan builds up and
knocks us down
this is a prestige dramedy about a
timely yet timeless story of an artist
struggling to find his voice and tribe
and so that's just an anonymous review
any questions you guys might have let me
know I prepared some if you if you don't
can't think of anything so Ryan that's
for you and me yeah you can go you have
a way of continually uh pending the
audience's expectations while also
fulfilling them in a satisfying way is
this something you consciously think
about
you know that's a good question I guess
I kind of go from the gut what I'm
writing it I don't know what do you
consider making the cat listen to that
music
animal abuse well I know that on a card
yeah the music's actually really good
it's made by my friend
Brooks Allison he's a wonderful musician
he's a songs out on Spotify if you want
to listen to black and blonde I've never
seen you promote anyone else this is
truly that means like Brooks you like he
really likes you that's like it's my
best friend Wow yeah
are you Brooks Allison I think you had a
question as well sure
I read okay Natacha :
you are this film's writer director and
producer no question here just Wow
that's it for show and tell thanks so
much for watching I feel like like a
good tired I feel sooo you're so glowing
[Music]
[Laughter]
that just ruin the whole show Chris is
technically right that's new tomorrow on
every damn day
[Music]
you